am I mated yes you are oh really yes you
are oh wait a second oh my God all right
here we go
look at that chess kid subtle branding
sticker on the table
I forgot Danny played this against me
and he won so I'm yeah you're in good
hands yep
I think it was an accident I think I
think I blacked out for those first two
games
I'm I'm really scared because you you're
moving with such confidence he doesn't
seem concerned whatsoever it's like it's
like really concerned it's extremely
concerning I don't understand
um this is secret okay your trip my prep
actually but like
so I have an option to take that gun I
don't know
um
wait Tony is this legit prep I have a
suggestion Tony why don't you take none
of my buns I just take none of them just
not just don't take any of my points
okay I won't take any of you okay
Deal's a deal force them to be taken
um
wow this is actually crazy about this
position no actually yes yeah it is like
actually
okay I mean this prep is praying off
wait a second
wait a minute yeah this was what I was
fearing when I actually were playing
this a little too focused here for me I
was supposed to be like more Goofy
I'm supposed to
kindness of D7
why did I think about that I mean this
is all prep I mean look at this
I watched the video of you today
before I was coming here I'm really
sorry and it was about a Mac that's
destroying everybody right were you
inspired he yeah I was inspired and he
hanged the pawn or not hanged he
sacrificed upon an opening first game
um and he sacrificed the pawn to have
major counter play okay and I'm inspired
by this so I'm doing exactly what he did
because you're giving me way more than
am I mated yes you are
really yes you are oh wait a second oh
my God
yes I think I'm missing my wallet
it's not a good thing everybody yay
we're gonna be one of those like epic
like oh my gosh that was
just like this whole time I was like ah
my king is safe Tony plays genius game
casually in the park
[Music]
thank you